everybody loves coffee  but how does coffee affects our brain  after consumption of coffee you feel  energetic but how does that work  so when we are thinking walking and  doing some job our neurons use atp as an  energy source atp gets eventually  converted to adenosine which in turns  bind to adenosine receptors in our  neurons adenosine has a negative impact  on our brain it slows down our neuronal  circuit and we feel tired  the active substance in coffee which is  known as caffeine has a similar  structure to that of adenosine  that is why caffeine can compete with  adenosine for the adenosine receptors  in simple word caffeine prevents  adenosine to bind to these adenosine  receptors and thereby lifting off  the inhibitory effect and thus we feel  energetic  subscribe for more